librairie salon coiffure banques hors
magasin d'articles de sport ont repris
leurs activités en grèce près de 10 %
des commerces ont rouvert hier
il faut dire que le pays a été
relativement épargné par le coronavirus
avec 146 décès et plus de 2600 cas de
contamination déclaré tous les autres
magasins à l'exception des centres
commerciaux ouvriront leurs portes le 11
mai le récit de robin pu l la vie
reprend peu à peu dans les rues
d'athènes
depuis ce lundi le gouvernement grec a
assoupli les restrictions imposées à sa
population
les habitants de la capitale peuvent
désormais circuler librement son
l'attestation qui était nécessaire
depuis le 23 mars
les autorités grecques ont cependant
imposer le port du masque dans les
transports en commun et certains
commerces une obligation plutôt bien
respectée par les usagers des transports
en commun ce qui rassure le syndicat des
travailleurs du métro athénien
depuis ce matin nous avons vu que des
passages et respectent des consignes
données par les médecins si cette même
cru dont celle observée dans les
prochains jours nous pensons que tout
ira bien
après 42 jours de confinement la vie
économique reprend également dans la
capitale
librairie magasin de biens électroniques
ou encore salons de coiffure ont rouvert
leurs portes
les gérants des commerces applique des
mesures sanitaires strictes afin
d'assurer la sécurité des salariés comme
des clients
lorsqu'un client entre dans le salon de
coiffure la première chose qu'il fait de
se désinfecter les mains
il ya du gel désinfectant à la réception
et à l'intérieur du salon ainsi que des
désinfectants pour les surfaces à chaque
nouveau client un assistant désinfecte
le poste de travail relativement
épargnée par l'épidémie la grèce tente
prudemment de relancer son économie
le déconfinement devrait se poursuivre
la semaine prochaine avec l'ouverture de
la plupart des commerces une troisième
phase prévue pour le 2 juin devrait
permettre la réouverture des hôtels et
des restaurants